What's your take on quoters?
Do you believe that they work
considering that you just said that last one that,
you know, if we have more than two,
two or more women in the final candidate list,
then they're 79% more likely to be there.
So what's your take on it?
I'm totally full cam for quotas.
Um, the reason that we,
we know we try
the unintentional bias is because we don't realize
we're doing it.
But when we have quotas and it has shown they does work,
quoters do drive change time and time again.
And so the quoters that are actually
instead of saying,
aiming for 50,
50, which is really challenging,
um, and that's when,
you know, the,
the problems could happen.
A model that has worked very well is the 40, 40, 20.
And so if you aim for 40% men,
40% women, and 20% can go either way,
you have that flexibility
and that model seems to really help drive, um,
gender balance in,
in, in leadership roles and boards.